The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so review
session on the first part
of the Fourier chapter, these
two topics that we've done
and that homework
is now coming on.
Fourier series, the
classical facts.
Plus, paying
attention to the rate
of decay of the
Fourier coefficients,
it's an aspect not
always mentioned.
And the energy
equality is important.
So it's not just here's the
function, find the coefficient.
That's part of it
but not all of it.
And then the discrete
series we were doing today.
OK, so those are the
two topics for today,
and then the next
review session,
which would be two
weeks from now,
would focus especially on
convolution and Fourier
integrals.
OK, so I'm open to
questions on the homework,
or off the homework.
Always fine.
I didn't know how many questions
to ask you on the homework.
I wanted you to have enough
practice doing this stuff
because the time for this
Fourier part of the course
is a little shorter.
Thanksgiving comes into it,
so needed to do some exercise.
And you've got a good question.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Number
18 on the homework, OK.
Ah yes, OK.
Right, alright.
So the idea of that
problem, I'm really
asking you to read the
two pages, the last two
pages of the section.
That use Fourier series to
solve the heat equation.
So we've used,
briefly, Fourier series
to solve Laplace's equation.
So that was, just to recall.
So Fourier series to
solve Laplace's equation
was when the region
was a circle.
The function was given, the
boundary values were given.
It's 2pi periodic
because it is a circle.
And we solved Laplace inside.
Because on the boundary,
the perfect thing we needed
was the Fourier series
to match the boundary.
Now, I'm taking another,
classical, classical
application too.
The heat equation.
So I made it heat equation.
So this direction is time,
this direction is space.
The heat equation is
u_t=u_xx, if the coefficient--
Everybody here knows there
would be a c in there,
but let's take it to be one.
Then what are the solutions,
and how does a Fourier series
help you to match the
initial functions?
So I'm matching, I'm
given u(x,0) here.
OK.
Along this is at time zero.
So that says at a time
zero, so I have a bar.
I have a conducting bar.
And this is such a
classical example
that I didn't feel you
could miss it completely.
Even though we look
beyond formulas.
But here's one where the formula
shows us something important.
OK, so what are solutions
to this equation?
You look for solutions,
so the classical idea
of separate variables.
Look for solutions that are of
the form some function of t,
maybe I'll try to use the
same letters as the text.
Some function of t, times
some function of x, OK?
And the text uses, look for
solutions u(x,t) that are
of this form.
Some function of t,
and I didn't remember.
Ah yes, it's A(x)B(t).
OK, that's what I
mean by separating.
So those will be especially
simple solutions.
And when we go to match
the initial condition,
I'll just plug in t=0
and I'll see the A(x)'s.
Well, what are they?
In this case, so their
eigenfunction-- oh,
I have to tell you about the
remaining boundary conditions,
don't I?
Because that will decide
what the A(x) has to satisfy,
and will decide what
those eigenfunctions are.
So, let's see.
In this problem I think
I picked free conditions.
So I made the interval minus
pi to pi, that's a change.
Minus pi to pi just so we
have nice Fourier series.
And here I have this boundary
is free, du/dx, u', at x=-pi,
for all time, so up
this line, is zero.
And also u' at plus pi,
and all time is zero.
So up those lines,
heat's going out.
That's what that means.
Is that what that means, or does
that mean heat can't go out?
No, so what's happening?
Heat's not going out.
Is that right?
The slope is zero, right?
The slope is the
temperature gradient,
we're requiring the
temperature gradient.
So the ends of the
bar are insulated.
So this is insulated.
No passage through, right?
Is that what that means?
Yeah.
It's like there's nobody,
it's cut off there.
The rod isn't extended
for heat to go further.
OK, so that tells us
what the x and the t,
what the A(x) and B(t) are.
So here's the point.
You plug that hoped-for solution
into the equation, right?
So I plug it in here.
What do I have on the left
side, just the time derivative?
So that's A times-- A(x)
B'(t), you see taking the time
derivative doesn't touch A(x).
On the right-hand side,
I don't touch B(t),
but I have a second
derivative of the x part.
So far, so good.
Now, a little trick.
If I divide both
sides by A and by B,
I get B'/B equaling
A''/A. Right?
Just, put the A under
here, put the B under here.
Now what?
This is neat, because
that function is only
depending on time.
This function depends only on
x, so that the both sides have
to be constant.
One can't actually change with
time, because this side is not
changing with time.
And this couldn't
actually change
with x, because that's
not changing with x.
So those are both constants.
So both constants.
Let's see, I'll maybe
just put a constant.
And various constants
are possible.
OK, so now you see
the point here.
Now I have two
separate equations,
I have an equation for
the B part, dB/dt, B'.
If I bring the B up
there, I have equals,
the constant times B. And I
know the solution to that.
B(t) is, as everybody
knows, what's
the solution to a first order
constant coefficient equation?
Just e^(ct)*B(0).
Good, we've got B. We've
got a B(t) that works,
and now what's the
A that also works?
That has A''.
And I bring the A up, so now I
have A''=cA, so the A that goes
with it is?
Oh, OK, I've used a c
there, so what's the good?
I want-- Two derivatives
should bring down a c.
Let me change c to
minus lambda squared.
How about if I look ahead,
change this constant to minus
lambda squared, because
I want something
where two derivatives bring
down minus lambda squared,
and what will do that?
Any amount of
cos(lambda*x), right?
Because two derivatives will
bring down a minus lambda
squared.
And any amount of sin(lambda*x).
And this is now e to the
minus lambda squared t.
I'm doing this fast, but
actually it's totally simple.
The conclusion is that I now
have a bunch of solutions
of this special separated form.
Where B(t) could be that and
A(x) could be either of those
or any combination of those.
And I have to use the
same lambda for each,
so that the two equations will
work in the original problem.
Good.
Now, so far, no
boundary conditions.
What I've got so far is
just a lot of solutions.
These times that.
With any lambda.
But of course the
boundary conditions
will tell me the
lambdas, first of all.
And how do they tell me?
The only boundary condition
I have is this free stuff.
So it's free, the slope should
be zero at pi, and zero at?
So that's the x direction.
So that's going to tell
me-- I've forgotten.
Do I want cosines or sines?
Cosines.
I want the derivative
to be zero at pi.
Yeah, so I think I
want cosines, good.
And then lambdas can't
be anything at all.
Because, should lambda be an
integer or something like that?
I think maybe lambda
should be an integer,
because I want to plug in pi.
So let me take the
second derivative.
Is minus lambda
squared cos(lambda*x).
And then I want to plug in x=pi.
And I want this to be zero.
So lambda should be an
integer, is that right?
At multiples of pi, the
cosine is zero, yes.
Is it?
No.
Did I want sine?
Maybe I wanted sine.
Oh, it's the first derivative
I'm looking at, thank you.
Thank you.
OK, good.
OK, now I've got it.
Thank you.
And now I see lambda
should be an integer.
Lambda should be, zero
is, yeah zero's alright.
That's the constant
term, yeah, we need that.
Zero, one, two, and so on.
So do you see that
I've now got, now I
can take-- I've got
a lot of solutions,
and I have a linear problem.
So I can take any combination.
So finally I have final
solution is that u(x,t) is any
combination, with coefficients
I'm free to choose, of A(x),
which is cos(nx), because
lambda had to be an n.
And n could be anywhere
from zero on up.
Times e to the minus, lambda
is n, so that's n squared t.
Did I get that?
Let me draw a circle
and step back.
What's up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: I
could have negative n's,
they wouldn't give me
anything new, right?
I mean cos(nx) and
cos(-nx) are just,
one's just the
negative of the other.
So these are the good guys.
I've got a cosine series because
I've got free n's, right.
Because of the
boundary conditions.
Do you see that?
That's pretty nice.
There's my A(x),
there's my B(t),
I can take any combination.
Usual stuff.
You get to that solution.
OK, and now I have to meet
the initial conditions, right?
Boundary conditions
are now built-in
because I chose cosine.
Or you did.
Now, this will tell
me what the c's are.
I'm going to set t=0.
At t=0, I'm given the
initial condition, u(x,0),
and I have the same
sum of c_n*cos(nx)*e^0.
So this will tell me the c's
are the cosine coefficients
of the given initial conditions.
So I expand, so here's where
Fourier series has paid off.
Expand the initial function
in a cosine series.
And then go forward in time.
This is just the
old e^(lambda*t).
Only the lambda we're talking
about here is minus n squared.
And you see what's
happening here?
What's going to
happen for large time?
So this is a very
physical problem.
That I think you cannot take
18.085 without seeing this
problem.
You can't learn
about Fourier series
without using it for
the initial value.
And then propagating in time
with the usual exponentials
for each one.
And now as n increases
what do I see?
Faster and faster decay.
For large n, these are going
to zero extremely fast.
So that what you see
with a solid bar, which
starts with the temperature
u in some-- Oh, probably
not negative unless
it's a really cold bar.
But, anyway, it starts with
some initial temperature.
That flattens out fast.
The heat flows, to equilibrate.
What I approach is the
constant term, c_0.
This approaches c_0.
Because all these other n
positives, they go to zero.
So the heat distributes
itself equally.
OK, and now I guess the
particular u(0) in the problem
was a delta.
OK, and so the
particular u(0) was all,
was from that really hot point.
So we know the coefficients.
We know the cosine coefficients
for the delta function,
we know these c's,
and what were they?
1/(2pi) was c_0.
And the other c's
were 1/pi, I think.
Is that right?
Maybe they're all 1/(2pi).
Maybe.
Yeah.
Whatever.
They disappear fast.
And this is what we approach.
So the heat from the
delta function is, yeah.
So is that everything
the problem wanted?
Yeah.
I think we've done it.
We'll put in the c_n's
to complete that picture.
Into here.
And then c_0 is the one
that survives over time.
Yeah.
I guess you've, once I got
rolling I couldn't stop
and that's u.
For investing time
this afternoon
you get a fast look at this
classical, classical problem
of separating the variables
using the Fourier series
for the initial function.
And recognizing that we're
doing this on a finite interval.
If the bar was
infinitely long, then we
would be talking about
Fourier integrals.
And that's what's
coming up a bit later.
We would integrate
instead of sum.
Yeah.
But the idea would
not be different,
if we had infinite
bar then we would not
be restricted to n
equals zero, one, two,
three; any n, any
cosine, wouldn't
have to be an integer at all.
Any number, any frequency
would be allowed.
And so we would have to
integrate that, yeah.
And that's a classical
problem too, again.
It's come up in a modern way,
that the famous Black-Scholes
equation.
So.
The heat equation is for 18.086.
Here, we brought it up because
we could solve it fast.
But the actual, yeah.
The most important
solution I could give you
to the heat equation would
be the one that starts
from that point source of heat.
But on the whole line.
The one that would be
integrals instead of sums.
Yeah.
So we came pretty close to
solving the most important heat
equation problem.
But we're doing the periodic
case, with just cosines,
and the infinite line case
would be the most famous of all.
Yeah.
And it has a
beautiful form, and I
was going to say that the heat
equation's pretty classical.
But let's see, where can I write
the magic words, Black-Scholes.
Next to the heat equation,
so that's the heat equation
but it's also-- do you know
these names, Black and Scholes?
Anybody in Mathematics
of Finance?
So these much-despised
option, derivative options,
so people on Wall
Street, traders,
will carry around a
little calculator that
solves the
Black-Scholes equation
so they can price the
options that they're
bidding to buy and sell, so
they can price them fast.
And that little calculator
does a finite differences,
or a Fourier series solution
to this Black-Scholes equation,
which actually, if you
change variables on it,
is the heat equation.
So what you see
here as is actually
important on Wall Street
except, it's probably not
the right moment to mention it.
Right?
So you can blame the whole
meltdown on mathematicians.
But that wouldn't
be entirely fair.
They didn't mean it, anyway.
But that's been the biggest
source of employment,
I guess, apart from teaching,
in the last ten years.
People who could work out
the partial differential
equations, and they get more
complicated than the heat
equation, you can be sure.
And so the classical
one, these guys
are economists at MIT and
Harvard, or they were.
And I guess maybe the
Nobel Prize in Economics
came to part of that group.
And also to Merton.
Maybe Black, possibly
Black died before the time
of the Nobel Prize.
Anyway, they were the first.
And it's a beautiful
paper, beautiful paper too.
Just to figure out
how do you price
the, what's the value
of an option to buy,
that allows you to buy or
sell a stock at a later time?
Yeah.
So it's, well of course you
have to make assumptions
on what's going to
happen over that time
and that's where Wall Street
came to grief, I guess.
If you had to put
it in a nutshell,
I mean, the options, the
standard straightforward
options, those are fine.
Using Black-Scholes,
and then what's happened
is they now price more and
more complicated things.
To the point that the banks
were buying and selling
credit default swaps, insurance
swaps, that practically nobody
understood what they were.
They just assumed that if there
was always a market for them,
like insurance, somehow
it wouldn't happen.
And you get on.
But it happened.
So, now we're in trouble.
OK, that's not
18.085, fortunately.
Or math, but.
Anyway, a lot of people
got involved with things
they didn't really know about.
And then were selling them as
well as of course the mortgage
problems.
Anyway.
Ready for other questions on
our homework, or these topics.
Yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK
PROFESSOR STRANG:
OK, right, yeah.
Have an image of waves, so --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
I suppose if I had to have a
picture of the discrete thing,
if my picture of
the function case
was a bunch of
sines, and cosines,
somehow adding up
to my function.
And if time, if I'm
solving the heat equation
then those separate waves
are maybe decaying in time.
Here.
So that when I add
them up at a later time
I get something different.
Or if it was the wave equation,
which is probably your image,
they're moving in time.
So they add up to different
things at different times,
because they can move
at different speeds.
Yes, so a function is
a sum of waves, right?
Then what would the
discrete guy be?
I guess I would just have to
imagine the function as only
having those n values.
And my wave would
just be, a wave
might be just n values there.
But still, if I have a
time-dependent problem,
maybe that thing is
pulsing up and down.
It's just that it's only got
a fixed number of points.
And I'm not looking at
the whole wave on a, yeah.
But I don't think it's
essentially different.
And of course, the fast Fourier
transform and the discrete case
is used to approximate
the continuous one.
Yeah.
You can look in
Numerical Recipes
for a discussion of
approximating the Fourier
series by discrete
Fourier series.
I mean, that's an
important question.
Because of course,
Fourier series
has got all these integrals.
The coefficients come
from an integral formula.
We're not going to do
those integrals exactly,
so we have to do them
some approximate way.
And one way would be to
use equally spaced points
and do the DFT.
Can you just remind me what
that integral formula is?
I don't want you to, it
was on the board today.
What's the formula for the
coefficient c_k in the Fourier
series.
I'm really just asking
you this because I
think you should have
it in some memory cache,
you know in fast memory,
rather than in the textbook.
OK, so what's the
formula for c_k,
in the Fourier series case?
Everybody think about it.
It's going to be
an integral, right?
And I'll take it over
zero to 2pi, I don't mind.
Or minus pi, pi.
And what do I integrate?
This is the Fourier coefficients
of the function f(x)?
So I take f(x), I
remember to divide by 2pi,
I'm doing the continuous
one, what do I multiply by
to get the coefficients?
e^(-ikx).
So I've forgotten
whether I assigned some
of these very early questions.
It just gave you the
function and said
what's the coefficient.
If I just look at one or two.
Suppose my function is f(x)=x.
I guess in that
problem, in Problem 1,
I made it minus pi to pi.
Suppose f(x)=x.
So you have to integrate
x times e^(-ikx).
Well, you got an integral to do.
OK, it's doable but
not instantly doable.
Let me ask you some questions
and you tell me about it.
So I draw the function.
The function is x
from minus pi to pi.
And tell me about
the coefficients,
how quickly do they decay?
This is like some constant
over k to some power p,
and what's p?
What rate of decay are you
expecting for the coefficients?
Well you say to yourself,
it looks like a pretty nice
function, smooth as can be.
But, what's the answer here?
The rate of decay will be,
what will that power be?
One.
Because the function jumps.
The function has a jump there,
and the Fourier coefficients
have got to deal with it.
So the Fourier series
for this is going to be,
if I took 100 terms it
would be really close.
And then it'll go down here to
the, but it's got to get there.
And got to start, and
pick up below there.
So it's got the same issue,
the Gibbs phenomenon,
that the square wave had.
It's got that jump.
So it'll go like 1/k.
OK, coming back.
Could you actually
find those numbers?
And do you remember how
to do integral like that?
Well, look it up, I
guess is the best answer.
But whoever did it
the first time, well,
it's integration
by parts, somehow.
The derivative of this
makes it real simple,
and this we can integrate
really easily, right?
So we integrate that, take
the derivative of that.
We get a boundary term,
so I don't exactly
remember the formula.
But it'll have a couple
of terms, but not bad.
And we'll see this 1/k.
OK, and that's the formula.
If I changed x to
something else, let's see.
As long as I'm looking at
number one, what if I took e^x?
Oh, easy.
Right? e^x, yeah, let's do e^x,
because that's an easy one.
Now, e^x looks like, so
what's my graph of e^x?
It's quite small here at minus
pi, and pretty large at e^pi.
What's the rate of
decay of the Fourier
coefficients for that guy?
Same.
Got to jump again.
Drops down here.
So let's find it.
Let's find those
Fourier, that integral.
That's e^(x-ik).
Sorry, let's put down
what I'm integrating here.
I'm integrating e to
the x times (1-ik).
Right?
That's what I've
got to integrate.
The integral is the same
thing divided by 1-ik.
I plug in the endpoints,
minus pi and pi,
and I've got the answer.
And I divide by 2pi.
Yeah.
So that's a totally doable one.
Let's plug it in.
1/(2pi).
And then the denominator is
this 1-ik, yeah, well there you
see it already, right?
You see already the
1/k in the denominator.
That's giving us
the slow decay rate.
And now I'm plugging
in equal-- equal--
e^(pi(1-ik)) minus
e^(-pi(1-ik)).
So as k gets big,
this is slow decay.
Now, what's happening
here as k gets large?
Oh, k is multiplied by i there.
So this e^(pi*ik)
is just sitting,
it may even be just one or
something, or minus one,
or whatever.
Is it?
Yeah. k is just an
integer, this is k*pi*i,
that's just minus
one to something.
So all that numerator
is minus one
to the to the k-th
power or something.
Times e^pi.
So e^pi is there. e^(-ik) at--
e^(-i*pi*k) is just minus one.
And this is maybe e to the minus
pi times the same, e^(+i*pi*k).
I think that's
minus one to the k.
Well, wait a minute.
Maybe they're not
both, whatever.
It's a number.
That's just of this size.
There's the big number,
there's the small one.
And divided by that,
that's the thing that shows
is yes, there is this jump.
Right?
OK, that's a couple of sets
of Fourier coefficients.
You could ask yourself,
because on the quiz
there'll probably
be one, and I'll
try to pick a function
that's interesting.
And I mean, I don't plan
to pick xe^x or anything.
Yeah.
OK, good.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Fourier series
has twice the energy as
another, what's that mean?
PROFESSOR STRANG: I don't know.
I guess.
Hm.
Maybe we're talking
about power, and things
like if we were dealing
with electronics,
I guess I would interpret
that energy in terms of power.
So that's what I'd be seeing.
I'm not thinking of
a really good answer
to say well, why is
that energy equality,
but it's really useful.
You know, so much of
signal processing,
and we'll do a bit
of signal processing,
is simply based on
that energy equality
there, and the moving
into frequency space.
And convolution.
Actually, they would
call it filtering.
So we'll call it filtering
when we use convolution.
But it's pure convolution.
Pure linear algebra,
for these special bases.
So, OK.
I could try to come up with a
better answer, or more focused
answer than just to say power
or, to use an electric power
word is just one step.
Yeah, thanks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
4.3, eight or nine.
Let's just have a look and
see what they're about.
OK, just some regular guys.
Yeah so that, OK,
let me look at,
you want me to do 4.3 eight?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Ah, yes.
Good, good question.
OK, so 4.3 eight gave
a couple of vectors,
a little bit like the
ones I did this morning.
I mean here the c in 4.3
eight has a couple of ones,
and this morning I just
had a [1, 0, 0, 0].
But no big deal.
Now, yeah.
So if two vectors
are orthogonal,
are their transforms orthogonal?
I think, yes.
Yes.
The Fourier, so the, yeah.
So maybe this is
worth a moment, here.
Yeah.
Because what do we,
let me write down
the letters for my question,
and then answer the question.
OK, so suppose I have
two vectors, c and d.
And they're orthogonal.
And then I want to
ask about their,
if I multiply by the Fourier
matrices, are those orthogonal?
That's sort of the question.
So here the vectors
in frequency space,
here they are in physical space.
I don't mind if you
started in physical space
and went to frequency with
F inverse, same question.
Does the Fourier
matrix preserve angles?
Does it preserve angles?
Do matrices, and F
wouldn't be the only one
with this property, do--
They preserve length, right?
If you preserve length, do
you preserve angles too?
Preserve length, you're
just looking at one vector.
We know that we preserve
length, and how do we know that?
Let's just remember that.
So here's the length question.
And this'll be the
angle question.
So this is the
energy inequality,
coming back to that key thing.
This is c bar transpose c,
and over here we have (Fc,Fc)
and this is what I
did this morning.
So that's c bar transpose
F bar transpose F c, right?
That's, why the bar as
well as the transpose?
Because we're doing complex.
OK, let me make a
little more space.
And what did we do this morning?
We replaced that by, well I
wish it were the identity.
But it's a multiple of the
identity, that's what matters.
So this was N, this is
the identity with an N,
c bar transpose c.
So the conclusion was that
this thing is just N times
this thing.
Well, and times this one.
I'm expecting oh, but
over here we got a zero.
So my N is going to wash out.
OK, let's just do the
same thing for angle.
This is the key energy
equality for length.
And all I want to say
is, this Fourier matrix,
like other orthogonal matrices,
is just rotating the space.
It's sort of
amazing to think you
have one space, physical
space, and you rotate it.
I'll use that word.
Because somehow that's what
an orthogonal matrix does.
Well it's complex
N-dimensional space.
Sorry, so it's not so easy to
visualize rotations in C^N,
but it's a rotation.
Angles don't change,
and let's just see why?
The inner product
of this with this
is c bar transpose,
F bar transpose,
because I have to
transpose that.
Times Fd, what do I do now?
This one was c bar
transpose d, with zero.
You see you have it?
Again, this fact that
this rotation and inverse,
and the transpose is the
identity, apart from an N. So
again, inner products
are multiplied
by N. Not only the
length squared,
which is inner
product with itself,
but all inner products
are just multiplied by N.
So if they start zero
they end up zero.
Yeah.
That was your question, right?
Yep, right.
So if I have a
couple of vectors,
as I guess that
problem proposed,
it happened to propose
two inputs that
happen to be
orthogonal, then you
should be able to see that
the transforms are, too.
Yeah.
Yep.
Can I ask you about question
two, was that on the homework?
Problem two in Section 4.3?
Was it?
All I want to say is
that's a simple fact.
Let me just write that fact down
so we're looking at that fact.
If I look at this F
matrix, it's so simple
but it leads to lots of
good, it's just a key fact.
But if I look at my F matrix,
am I looking at rows here?
Yeah, I happened
to look at rows,
columns would be the
same, it's symmetric.
So here's row one, here's row
two, I'm sorry that's row zero.
This is row one.
And let me look at row N-1.
This is w, w^(N-1), this
was w^2, this is w^(2(N-1)).
And so on.
Everybody's got
the idea of the--
And then all these in-between
rows, two, three, et cetera.
And the question asks,
show that this and this
are complex conjugates.
That that row and that row are
the same, except conjugates.
So if we look at the
row number one in F,
we'll be looking at row
number N-1 in F bar.
Now, why is that row the
conjugate of that row?
Why is this the
conjugate of this?
Why are those two conjugates?
So I'm asking you to explain
to me why w bar is the, why
is the conjugate of this, this?
So it's just one more neat fact
about these important, crucial,
numbers w.
And so how do I see this?
Well, this is w-- This
is one way to do it.
This is w^N times w^(-1).
And what's w^N?
One.
Everybody knows, w^N is one.
So I have w, so I'm
trying to show that.
Well, we know that this is true.
So we know that the
conjugate of w, right?
There's w.
Here's its conjugate, and
it's also the inverse.
This w is some e^(i*theta),
this is some e to the the i some
angle.
Then always, it's sitting
on the unit circle.
So its reciprocal is
also on the unit circle.
The reciprocal has e^(-i*theta),
so it's just the conjugate.
That's a great fact.
That's a beautiful fact
about all these w's.
And their powers.
Conjugate and inverse the same.
Right.
So that was the
key to problem two.
I don't think I asked
you to go through all
the steps of problem
three, but just in case
you didn't read problem
three, let me tell you
in one tiny space what happens.
In problem three you discover
that the fourth power of F
is the identity.
Except there is an N squared,
because from two F's we got
an N, so from four F's-- So
that's another fantastic fact
about the Fourier matrix.
That its fourth power,
it must be somehow,
the Fourier matrix
is rotating, yeah.
Somehow, I don't
know, how do you
understand that the
Fourier matrix is,
its fourth power brings
you back to the identity.
Apart from, we just
didn't normalize it.
So that we wouldn't, to
avoid that N squared,
so we had to use it.
Yeah.
That's pretty amazing.
Pretty amazing.
So if I had normalized
it right, if I
took F over the square
root of N, that's
the exact normalization
to give me a,
to put the N's where they
belong, you could say.
Then the fourth power of
that matrix is the identity.
Yeah.
New math and new applications
keep coming for these things.
I'll tell you, actually.
You could tell me
eigenvalues of this matrix.
Yeah, this is a good question.
What are the eigenvalues
of a matrix whose fourth
power is the identity?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, one.
What else could
the eigenvalue be?
If the fourth power
of the matrix is I,
what are the
possible eigenvalues?
So let me, so this matrix is,
can I call it M for the-- Or
maybe U for the matrix F--
So if U^4 is the identity,
what are the eigenvalues?
What could, well of course
u could be the identity,
but it's not.
It's the Fourier matrix.
So the eigenvalues could be
one, what else could they be?
Minus one is possible.
Because minus the identity,
that'd be fine. i, and minus i.
Four possible eigenvalues.
And when the matrix
reaches, I think
if you put the four by four
Fourier-- I don't know.
If you, say, put the
four by four Fourier
matrix into MATLAB, and see
what you get for eigenvalues,
I've forgotten whether you
get one of each of these.
Or whether somebody's
repeated at the level four,
but then go up to
five or six you'll
see these guys start showing up.
Different multiplicity.
Right?
The 1,024 matrix
has got these guys.
Some number of times,
adding up to a 1,024.
Right, yeah.
So it's quite neat.
Now, here's a question,
which I actually
just learned a good answer to.
What are the eigenvectors?
You could give a sort of
half-baked description.
Because once you
know the eigenvalues.
But to really get a handle on
the eigenvectors, that's has
been a problem that was studied
in IEEE transactions papers.
But not really the right, not
a nice specific description
of the eigenvectors.
And somebody was in my
office, this fall, a guy,
post-doc at Berkeley
who's seen the right way
to look at that problem and
describe the eigenvectors
of the Fourier matrix.
So that's, like,
amazing to me that such
a fundamental
question was waiting.
And turned out to involve
quite important, deep ideas.
OK, ready for one
more for today?
Anything?
Or not.
OK, so I hope you're
getting the good stuff now
on the Fourier series.
Fourier discrete transform.
Please come on Friday,
because Friday will
be the big day for convolution.
And that's the essential thing
that we still have to do.
OK, see you Friday.